well so you mentioned einstein
predicted that black holes don't exist
or just or
exist in nature when einstein came up
with his theory of gravity in 1915
november 1915
a few months later another physicist
carl schwarzschild he was the director
of the potsdam observatory but he was a
patriot a german patriot
so he went into the first world war
fighting for germany but
while he was at the front he sent a
postcard to einstein saying you know a
few months after the theory was
developed
saying actually i found a solution to
your equations
and that was the black hole solution and
then he died a few months later
einstein was a pacifist and he survived
so the the lesson from this story is
that
if you want to work out the consequences
of a theory
you better wear pacifists but
but the point is that this solution was
known
shortly after einstein came up with his
theory but in
but in 1939 einstein wrote a paper
in the analysis of mathematics saying
even though the solution exists
i don't think it's realized in nature
and his argument was
if you imagine a star collapsing
stars often spin and the spin will
prevent them from making a black hole
collapsing to a point
you